today's usa
today um did a story on people making
stuff happen with their shows
on the internets i was very fortunate
to get a plug for my show very happy
and excited but also very disappointed
it is the middle of 2008 my friends
and i've been screaming on tour for
about a year now
about personal brand the gold rush a
personal brand
and it blows my mind that more people
aren't attacking the space
the barber the lawn mower person the
landscaper whatever you want to say
you know the babysitter the sushi chef
we're the movie critics
sports center should be totally spoofed
and made raw
on web 2.0 video right now but yet there
are still
hardly any niche shows that are really
dominating
it blows my mind it blows my mind that
people have not jumped on this bandwagon
just like the gold rush for gold
this is gonna end it's gonna end and the
30th family that came to california
despite that gold
definitely didn't make as much and so
what are you waiting for talk about what
you love
your little niche and if that's the
university of kentucky basketball
that could be a huge show too you will
find your sponsorship
you will they're going to figure it out
the marketers are going to figure it out
i promise
it's a little patience my friends but
start building your audience
start putting out a show talk about what
you love and then
fester and nourish that community
respond to the emails
be a part of the conversation in your
little niche and if that's
alf season 2 or the wonder years or
small wonder
or whatever it may be it could be
anything why pluto is no longer
a planet i could care less but pick what
you're passionate about
talk about it every day five days a week
seven days a week
pump it out as hard as you can and
realize we are in a gold rush
don't miss out